thank you the Trojan War arguably one of Greek
mythology's largest and most significant events
some of its most epic battles between its greatest
heroes and yet if someone was to ask me to
summarize the Trojan War I'd shrug my shoulders
and probably walk away it's a confusing series
of events with conflicting goals infighting
and just general confusion unfortunately we
do not have an overarching text that details
the events of the Trojan War it's split into
various different texts poems and passages we
do however have some detailed accounts from epic
such as Homer's Iliad and Virgil's Aeneid that
allow us to patch together a somewhat coherent
story hopefully today I'll be able to fill in
the gaps and explain the events that took place
before we continue a quick word from today's
sponsor kamikoto knives preparing food can be
a pain especially when the tools at your disposal
are not very good kamikoto knives are made from
the finest Japanese steel using only steel that
has been sourced from Japanese meals kamikoto uses
techniques that date back to the Edo period and
every one of their knives goes through a 19-step
process that can take several years from start
to finish this results in meticulously crafted
knives with polished and sharpened edges that
just can't be matched by a regular knife kamikoto
knives are individually inspected to make sure
they reach the high standards one expects from
Japanese steel they are so confident in the
quality of their knives they offer a lifetime
guarantee and they Pride themselves on excellent
customer service from the creation of their knives
to Quick clear and concise response answers to
customer queries kamikoto are also the knives
of choice for Michelin star chefs all around the
world all of this sounds great so far but what
about my experience now I'm no connoisseur when
it comes to kitchen knives but I can say they
were easily the sharpest and the highest quality
knives I've used before the heavy duty Ashwood
box that they come in makes them an ideal gift
and this year they were my Mother's Day gift of
choice now of course you may find yourself trying
to slice your way through random objects to see
how good these knives really are but take it from
my experience there isn't much that survives this
test if your interest has been peaked kamikoto
are offering my viewers a Black Friday sale where
you can receive an extra fifty dollars off your
order when using the code mythology and fiction
you can also visit kamikoto.com mythology
and fiction to help support the Channel
simply put the Trojan War took place between
the Mycenaean Kingdom and the kingdom of Troy
the Mycenaean Kingdom were also referred to as
the acadians or Acadian Greeks which for anyone
already confused just meant primitive or ancient
Greeks for the sake of avoiding confusion there
were Greek Heroes and soldiers who fought on both
sides but those who sided with Troy I'll just be
referring to as Trojans the Greeks or achaeans
will be the terms used for those who sided with
Greece against Troy the war itself took place
because of the Abduction of the Spartan Queen
Helen by the Trojan Prince Paris however to fully
understand how these events transpired we have to
go much further back as far back as the prophecy
that stated Zeus would be overthrown by one
of his children when Zeus and Poseidon first saw
the beautiful nymph of the sea thetas they were
both more than entertained at the idea of making
her their bride however they both reconsidered
after hearing the prophecy surrounding thetas and
her son her son was fated to be stronger than his
father he would possess a weapon stronger than
Zeus's Thunder and Poseidon's trident Zeus not
wanting to be overthrown by his son decided that
fetus would instead marry King peleus their son
would still possess great power but nothing
to rival Zeus and Poseidon for those wondering
this sun was indeed Achilles who would play his
own part in the Trojan War Zeus had planned a
mighty feast and celebrations that anyone of any
note or importance was invited to the only deity
be not invited to these celebrations was Eris the
goddess of Discord and strife in hindsight we know
this completely backfired and placed into motion
the events that caused the Trojan War is turned
up to the celebrations with a gift in hand and
she was essentially turned away at the door as
instructed by Zeus unsurprisingly she was rather
angry at being denied entry whilst at every other
day as he enjoyed the hospitality she took her
gift which was a golden apple and threw it amongst
the guests before turning around and leaving
the Apple was inscribed with the message to the
fairest which one would assume was a wedding gift
for the bride however the Apple had fallen between
Athena Hera and Aphrodite the three goddesses
began to argue each one claiming the Apple was
intended for them as they were the fairest looking
for a resolution they soon turned to the crowd who
wisely chose to not take aside eventually they
took this dispute to Zeus and asked him to decide
who was the fairest of the three Zeus also not
wanting anything to do with this had Hermes take
the three goddesses to Mount Ida where they would
be judged by a young Shepherd this Shepherd was
Paris a prince of Troy Zeus in a hurry to pass the
buck to the next unfortunate individual had told
Paris he could decide the winner of this beauty
contest any way he saw fit when Paris was ready
all three goddesses undressed so he could see
them naked this resulted in another stalemate
with Paris declaring they were all of identical
beauty of course this was the incorrect answer and
so we move on to the next stage bribery all three
goddesses offered Paris something in return for
his vote Hera offered him status as well as the
the very small ownership of the entirety of Europe
and Asia Athena offered Paris wisdom and the skill
to match the greatest warriors in battle Aphrodite
offered him love and the most beautiful bride on
Earth Paris chose love and declared Aphrodite to
be the fairest of all unfortunately Aphrodite
failed to mention that this beautiful bride was
Helen of Sparta who was already married to the
King of Sparta Menelaus if Paris wanted to marry
Helen he would have to travel to Sparta and kidnap
her there are varying accounts of what happens
next under the guise of a diplomatic expedition
to Sparta Helen saw Paris fell instantly in love
and followed him willingly back to Troy in other
other accounts Aphrodite sent Eros who shot Helen
with an arrow causing her to fall in love with
Paris and making the abduction slightly easier
King Menelaus was the brother of King Agamemnon
who ruled over mycenaea and what many considered
to be the entirety of ancient Greece it wasn't
difficult to convince him to join his cause and
wage war against Troy until Helen was returned
it doesn't however explain the sheer numbers
and heroes the Greeks were able to Rally this ties
back to Helen and her father Helen was considered
the most beautiful woman across ancient Greece
and so she had many suitors chasing her hand in
marriage under the advice of Odysseus Helen's
father convinced all these suitors to swear an
oath that despite whoever he chooses to marry his
daughter they will always fight for Helen's honor
with Helen's disappearance her father invoked the
oath and so Menelaus had almost the entirety of
ancient Greece from its Kings generals and heroes
at his disposal to try and return Helen to Sparta
Troy was a very prosperous and well-fortified
City ruled by King Priam who along with his
wife hecuba had over 50 Children whilst hecuba
was pregnant she had a nightmare where she gave
birth to a flaming torch as weird as it sounds
it was important enough for her to explain to
a Seer known as asicus who also happened to be
one of her children he interpreted the dream or
nightmare to mean the prosperity and good fortune
of Troy would come to an end the flaming torch was
symbolic of the burning of their Homeland and the
fall of Troy on the day the child was born asakus
saw visions of a royal child of Troy responsible
for its end this child was Paris the Sears and
Priests looked to Apollo for guidance and the
only way to save Troy was by killing the child
however once Paris was born priyam and hecuba
couldn't bring themselves to kill their child
instead Priam gave him to his head Shepherd agules
and asked him to kill the child the shepherd also
couldn't bring himself to kill the child and so
he took him to Mount Ida hoping the Wilderness
and elements would take care of him Paris was
nursed by a female bear and so starvation was
no issue after seven days a young Paris returned
to agaleas stunned that the boy hadn't perished he
would raise him as his own he took Priam a dog's
tongue as proof that the deed had been done pair
Paris began to establish himself as more than
just a regular Shepherd fighting off a gang of
Bandits trying to steal cattle and returning them
to their owners before long he had earned the name
Paris Alexander a surname that meant protector
of men amongst agules heard Paris had found the
strongest Bull and challenged the Shepherds to
try and best his Bull with one of their own none
could do so and so he extended his invitation
to anyone in Greece claiming he would give a
Golden Crown to anyone who could this challenge
was accepted by the god de Ares who transformed
himself into a bull and defeated paris's Bull
with ease Paris was a man of his word and gave
Ares the Golden Crown as promised to the gods this
established him as an honest man which is why when
they needed someone to judge a certain beauty
contest Zeus had no hesitation in turning to
Paris having heard his reputation as an honest
man so those were the events that transpired
and ultimately caused the Trojan War however this
war took place over many years it wasn't just one
or two battles the Greeks couldn't just endlessly
keep throwing their armies at the Trojans despite
having the numbers in their favor the city of
Troy was an impenetrable Fortress its walls were
built by Apollo and Poseidon as punishment for
their Rebellion against Zeus he sentenced them
to years of hard labor and part of this consisted
of building and fortifying the walls of Troy the
war is usually broken down into smaller battles
and skirmishes that lasted around 10 years into
terms of who sided with who Agamemnon had amassed
a massive Army from all the major regions in
Greece Sparta Athens Crete Corinth Arcadia Rhodes
and several other cities and states we don't have
an exact number for the total Army but it said the
Greeks sailed thousands of ships to Troy Homer's
description was even so there are many tribes
poured forth from ships and Huts into the plane of
scamander and the Earth echoed wondrously beneath
the tread of men and horses so they took their
stand in the flowery Mead of scamander numberless
as the leaves and flowers in their season this is
often simplified as there were as many men as the
leaves and flowers in the springtime pretty much
Homer's way of saying the Greeks had a very big
army the Greeks also had some very iconic Heroes
on aside Achilles Ajax diomedes and Odysseus are
just a few of the more recognizable ones Odysseus
upon learning that taking part in the Trojan War
would mean being away from his home for 20 years
tried to feign insanity but upon his lie being
unraveled he had no choice but to answer the cause
of Greece king Menelaus and Odysseus attempted
The Diplomatic approach and tried to negotiate
the return of Helen but they were met with no
interest from Troy and so war was the only option
after essentially being rejected by Paris Athena
and Hera both sided with the Greek army playing
important roles assisted by Hermes Poseidon fetus
and Hephaestus Aphrodite naturally sided with
Paris and the Trojans as well as having assistance
from a Hollow Artemis and Aries they also had some
formidable fighters of their own Hector being the
most feared at the time he was compared to the
demigods despite this not being true it's still a
fairly good reflection of Hector's reputation Zeus
occasionally interfered where he saw fit but
for the most part preferred to remain neutral
and his army gathered at the Port Town of orlis
where all the kings and Generals would send
for their armies to honor their oath the king of
Crete Ida menaeus requested Agamemnon made him his
co-commander and in exchange he would gladly send
the full force of Crete to support the war on Troy
another of agamemnon's commanders was Achilles
who at this point was only 15 years old but had
already earned the respect of his peers and fear
of his enemies before leaving Orla say sacrifice
was made to Apollo The Seer calcus who had a
very strong connection to the god interpreted the
results to mean that Troy would indeed fall but
only after 10 years of war the Greek set sail and
landed in my Seer mistaking it for Troy once on
the shore The Siege began which resulted in many
casualties for the natives including their King
telephus who was almost killed by Achilles mysia
were allies of Troy and their king would surely
possess some knowledge in how to sack the city
he was taken back to all this as a hostage at the
very least they could have him plot the correct
course to try back in all this King telephus
refused to cooperate with Agamemnon until the
spear wound he suffered from Achilles was healed
eventually Achilles agreed to remove the shards of
Spear and telephone showed the Greeks how to reach
Troy Agamemnon was now faced with a new issue
every time they set sail from all this they were
met with extreme winds that dispersed the fleet
and made reaching Troy together impossible they
turned to The Seer calcus once again for answer
is he was told that the winds were punishment
from Artemis because Agamemnon had killed her
sacred deer the only way to appease Artemis was by
sacrificing his own daughter ephogenia naturally
he refused at first however now facing a mutiny
and the possibility of a new Commander taking his
place he had no option but to accept just before
Agamemnon sacrificed ephogenia Artemis intervened
and swapped his daughter for a lamb ephogenia
became a priestess of Artemis and with agamemnon's
commitment and loyalty proven she would allow
their fleets to finally set sail and begin their
Voyage to Troy this back and forth from Alice and
mycia with the winds blocking and dispersing the
fleet went on for a significant amount of time
some sources say it was several years and others
go as high as eight so the 20 years away from
home Odysseus was prophesized doesn't seem too
crazy seeing as this 10-year War hasn't even begun
and we could possibly already be eight years in
the full force of agamemnon's fleet was finally
able to set sail we may not have an exact number
for the size of this Fleet but we do have some
descriptions that give us a rough estimate Homer
describes 28 regions of Greece amassing 1186 boats
each one containing 50 rowers a few other accounts
put this number at around 1200 ships each one with
a crew of 120 men historians took these numbers
as examples of minimum and maximum capacity and
they estimate the forces that sailed to Troy would
have been between 70 and 130 000 upon reaching the
Trojan Beach calcus prophesies the first archaean
to set foot on land would die this resulted in
the first Ships coming to a halt at the shore and
waiting for someone else to make the first move in
order to avoid the prophecy Odysseus demonstrating
his guile managed to end this awkward standoff
between the achaeans make himself appear fearless
and avoid calcus prophecy all at the same time he
threw his shield on the ground and when he jumped
off his ship he landed on the shield technically
he did not touch land and therefore was not the
first man on the Trojan Shore next to follow
was the hero protocilius who we know was the
first man to step foot on land no one expected the
Trojans to leave their heavily fortified City and
meet the Greeks head-on who had a vastly superior
Army expecting the invading Army to be tired from
their Voyage Hector led a small group of soldiers
who hid on the beach waiting for their enemy's
arrival the first wave of the Cayenne troops were
certainly caught off guard and the unfortunate
protossilius who believed he was not the first man
on land was killed by Hector this plan only worked
for a short period of time as more akaian ships
landed on the beach the Trojans would eventually
be overwhelmed Hector was forced to pull his
men back in Retreats towards the city the first
encounter set the tone for much of the war most
of it took place outside of the walls of Troy
Hector and his men did have one more small-scale
encounter with the akaian forces before retreating
to the city walls this time without the element
of surprise they suffered heavy losses and had
no choice but to flee the majority of battles
that took place for the next nine years were
just outside of the city wars as the Trojans had
no choice but to surrender the remaining land as
its defense wasn't possible in these battles the
gods would intervene as they saw fit blocking
Spears and arrows as well as creating distractions
to make retreating easier there are even accounts
of God's teleporting soldiers away just before
they were killed the first nine years of this
war consisted of the Greeks keeping the Trojans
trapped inside their City while systematically
destroying the neighboring cities and the allies
of Troy at times the Greeks were Their Own Worst
Enemy with many disagreements causing them to
turn on each other palomedes was the individual
responsible for exposing Odysseus's lie about him
being insane so some ill feelings already existed
between the two with supplies low Odysseus was
sent to Thrace to collect grain and food returning
empty-handed resulted in palomedes questioning the
usefulness of the hero and so he told palomedes
to do better if he could palamidi's set sail and
returned with a ship full of grain which of course
angered Odysseus to the point where in one story
Odysseus and diomedes drowned the palomedes whilst
he was fishing an alternate story has Odysseus
plant to gold in palomidi's quarters and then
Forge a letter from King Priam to palamedes
making it appear as if he betrayed the Greeks to
the Trojans for gold Agamemnon wouldn't tolerate
such treachery and so palamides were stoned to
death the lack of food and supplies was enough to
cause a mutiny from the entire Army threatening
to sail back to Greece a combination of Achilles
and Agamemnon enlisting the three daughters of
Aeneas ended the Mutiny the daughters were able
to turn anything they wanted into wine wheat and
oil so the supply issue was no longer affecting
morale I'm sure what many have been waiting to
hear about were the battles themselves and the
individual skirmishes early on in an attempt to
end this war fairly without any more Bloodshed
there was a duel agreed between Menelaus and
Paris the prize being Helen they picked up their
Spears and Drew lots to see who would be first
Paris winning here took a step back and threw
his spear Menelaus lifted his shield and blocked
what was a rather tame throw he then returned the
favor with far more aggression splitting paris's
shield and piercing his armor Paris was lucky
that his attempt to dodge the spear resulted in
a non-fatal wound Menelaus seeing his chance
charged towards Paris swinging his swords so
hard it shattered against paris's helmet he then
grabbed Paris by the helmet and dragged him around
the battlefield in front of his men sensing an
easy Victory Aphrodite watching on refused to let
Paris die wrapping him in a cloud he sent him back
to the city before Menelaus could finish the job
diomedes was the youngest of the Greek Kings
to join the war to many he was second only
to Achilles in terms of skill in combat and his
bravery Homer's Ilia doesn't cover large portions
of the war outside of the key battle and final
stages but diamedes is a name that appears perhaps
the most of all the heroes that took part in the
war what sets diomedes apart from the other Heroes
was his wisdom and tactical knowledge he played
a huge role in the battles themselves but also
played a large role behind the scenes in planning
and strategizing in a sparring contest with Ajax
the two tested each other's limits even the men
watching called for the contest to come to an end
in fear that one would be seriously harmed Ajax
presented diomedes with a long sword as a prize
given he was able to draw First Blood in their
Spa diomedes was Athena's favorite hero and he
was the only mortal or demigod other than Heracles
to harm an Olympian deity during many battles
diomedes ran through the Trojan ranks with ease
and almost caused them to retreat single-handedly
he had been emboldened by the cause of Athena
as her Champion his shield and helmet would glow
with fire diomedes had slain numerous Trojan
Heroes including several of King priam's sons
in one Skirmish Apollo stirred the Trojan troops
and they remained on the battlefield the Trojan
Warrior panderers threw his Spear and wounded
diamedes in the shoulder panderas posted that he
had just killed the mighty diamede son of tideus
he was too busy celebrating to see diomedes remove
the spear and begin walking over diomedes threw
pandoras's spear back at him and the celebration
stopped as he instantly died in front of diomedes
was Aeneas the son of Aphrodite without any
weapons diomedes grabbed a large Boulder and hold
it ateneus crushing the hero's hip he also fell to
the ground Aphrodite intervened just in time and
was able to rescue her son before she was able
to Retreat diomedes through pandoras's spear once
again and grazed Aphrodite's and this drew blood
and she dropped her son and fled she took this
dispute to Zeus infuriated that a man would dare
to attack her Zeus refused to intervene claiming
that acts of War and the Affairs of man were the
responsibilities of Ares and Athena Apollo stepped
in between diomedes andanius heeding him to listen
to Athena and stop his attacks Against The Gods
diomedes attacked Apollo numerous times without
any success an enraged Apollo reminded diamedes
he was no match for the gods and another attack
would result in his death Apollo retreated with
the wounded Aeneas he urged Ares and Hector who
had just joined the battle to make diomedes pay
for his disrespect diamede seeing the God of War
pulled his men back and began a slow Retreat
Hera and Athena seeing the achaeans in need
of aid offered their assistance Athena took a
chariot and using the helmet of Hades was able
to cloak herself convincing diomedes to attack
Aries they charged towards him Aries only saw
diomedes and through his spear Athena was able to
to catch the spear aimed at diomedes and guided
diomedes when he threw his own spear the spear
Court Aries in the abdomen the God let out a cry
as loud as a thousand men and had no choice but to
retreat from the battle diamedes had now wounded
two Olympians in one day and slain countless
Trojan Heroes and Soldiers the Trojans were so
scared of diomedes they even made a substantial
offering to Athena pleading for her to break his
spear an offering she unsurprisingly declined
with the tide starting to turn in the akaian's
favor Zeus declared on this particular day all
deities must Retreat from Troy and allow the
men to resolve their issues unimpeded as the gods
left Zeus conjured a mighty storm and rained down
lightning upon the Acadian Army all the kings and
heroes jumped on their horses and tried to escape
the storm Nestor was left behind because his horse
had been wounded by Paris diomedes noticing Nestor
missing turned around and went back to rescue
him the achaeans took this as a sign that Zeus
had sided against them and perhaps the war was
no longer worth fighting even Agamemnon began
to question if he could lead this Army to victory
Zeus had sent an eagle as a sign of good faith and
diomedes was the only one to notice he convinced
the achaeans that they had been prophesied to win
this war and Zeus's involvement would not change
this throughout the war diomedes was the akaian
backbone he was the first to volunteer and the
last to retreat without him the war would have
been difficult maybe even impossible with Hector
being one of the Trojan's most formidable Heroes
and Fighters he does appear several times
throughout the war one of the events that
sparked a series of deaths in the war was the
death of patroclus a childhood friend of Achilles
patroclus convinced Achilles to allow him to
lead a small group of men to repel the Trojan
forces trying to destroy their ships Achilles
agreed and gave him the armor his own father
had given him so he could impersonate Achilles
and strike fear into the Trojan forces this plan
was a success with patroclus mowing through the
Trojans with ease however he became overzealous
the Trojans retreated from the ships but patroclus
continued to chase reaching the gates of Troy here
he killed more Trojan soldiers even killing
demigods and Sons of Zeus such as sarpadon
Apollo was able to distract patroclus long enough
for him to be hit by a spear weakened he was then
killed when Hector took the spear and stabbed
him in the abdomen believing he had just killed
Achilles when Achilles had heard the news along
with Ajax and Menelaus they rode out to collect
his Fallen friend's body Achilles wouldn't allow
the burial of his friend until his ghost appeared
to him and demanded a burial to allow him to pass
to the underworld if the Trojans feared Achilles
before they would now have to deal with a much
angrier Achilles who was looking for vengeance
Hector then had two more encounters with Ajax
who is also known as Ajax greater the first of
which was a duel that lasted almost an entire day
Ajax had the upper hand knocking down Hector with
a large Rock and wounding him with a spear however
Zeus intervened calling the doll a draw as it had
gone on for long enough each Warrior gave the
other a gift Ajax gave Hector a purple belt and
in return received a sword the second encounter
was when Hector and his men attacked the Greek
ships Ajax again held a large rocket Hector and
almost decapitated him luckily Apollo was there
to heal and restore Hector Ajax took his mighty
Spear and with most of the Greek army asleep he
fought off this Trojan attack by himself Achilles
in dispute with Agamemnon refused to assist
Ajax was eventually disarmed by Hector with some
slight intervention from Zeus and was forced to
retreat hexa and the Trojans had only managed to
burn down one ship and had suffered heavy losses
but it was clear who Zeus favored between the two
Hera was able to distract Zeus for long enough
that Poseidon could intervene making the Greeks
aware of this attack so they could assist Ajax it
was Achilles who would take the bigger scalp and
put an end to the biggest thorn in the Greek side
Hector when he killed patroclus Hector stripped
him of the legendary armor and gave it to his
men to take back to the city however there was
some descent hexa had just killed a boy and not
the mighty Achilles he had been bested by Ajax in
their eyes and refused to challenge him there were
shouts of cowardice and so Hector put on Achilles
armor and rallied his men men claiming that it
would now make him Invincible seeing him Don the
armor and make these claims were foolish to Zeus
and he could foresee Hector's demise the newly
emboldened Hector waited outside to challenge
Achilles however he had a change in mind and tried
to flee Achilles gave Chase but it was Hector's
brother that cleared his mind and prepared him
for the duel the trick is that this brother was
actually Athena in Disguise feeding him delusions
of grandeur of what he would become when he
defeated Achilles Hector made only one request
the Victor was to return the other one's body
for burial the fight began with Achilles charging
towards Hector and hurling his spear Hector was
just able to move out of the way Athena watching
took the spear and instantly placed it back in
Achilles hand without anyone noticing wearing the
helmet of Hades she was still invisible hexa then
threw his spear but achilles parried with his
shield he turned to his brother to supply him
with another spear however Athena's trickery had
worked as there was no one there instead he drew
his sword knowing that his fate had been decided
Achilles could see that hexa's collarbone was
exposed and through his spear finding the weak
spot hexa fell to the ground and with the time
he had left pleaded with Achilles to allow him
an honorable funeral Achilles told him he would
allow the dogs and vultures to devour his flesh
which after what happened to Patrol vocalists
makes sense hexa died but not before prophesizing
that Achilles would also die soon using the belt
given to Hector by Ajax he tied the corpse to his
Chariot by the feet and then proceeded to drag
the corpse across the city showing the Trojans
how easily he had just slain their most feared
Warrior he continued to drag the body around for
12 days which prompted Apollo and Aphrodite to
intervene enchanting the body and preserving it
from receiving it any more damage after 12 days
the gods agreed Achilles had had enough fun and it
was time to return the body they sent Iris and the
thetas to relay the message thesis visited her son
and persuaded him to allow King Priam to come and
claim his son's body Iris did the same explaining
the terms to the Trojan King King Priam agreed to
go alone and retrieve his son's body but Hermes
gave him a charm that made anyone who looked at
him fall asleep making passage much safer Achilles
surrendered the body to King Priam for the agreed
Ransom and a 12-day truce was called between the
two sides whilst funeral rites were administered
with the truce over Achilles continued his Trojan
bloodbath outside of the city but even the great
Achilles had a weakness when he was born thetas
took her son and made him almost Invincible by
dipping him in the river sticks the only part
of his body that was not submersed was the heal
his mother held him by making this the only
vulnerable part of his body outside the gates
of Troy Paris took aim at Achilles and fired an
arrow Guided by Apollo his Arrow was true and
struck Achilles in his heel a wound that would
eventually kill him some poets claim that it was
Apollo disguised as Paris who fired at the arrow
Odysseus and Ajax fought bravely to reclaim his
body and give him the burial he deserved next
to his friend patroclus the death of Achilles
caused the Greeks more problems than just losing
their best soldier who received his armor became
a point of contention Ajax claimed that he had
slain more Trojans than anyone else there's no
denying that Ajax was a phenomenal Warrior
but his speech making skills were lacking
Odysseus with assistance from Athena delivered
a more eloquent and convincing argument as
to why he deserved the armor when the council
voted they decided the armor would be given to
Odysseus Ajax feeling an overwhelming amount of
Shame and disrespect killed himself a strange and
fairly underwhelming end to one of the war's
standout warriors with Achilles and Ajax dead
the Greeks began to worry whether this war
would ever end they turned to calcus again
who spoke of Visions regarding the arrows
of Heracles without these they would not be
victorious unfortunately Heracles arrows were
in the hands of his good friend of philoctatis
who they had abandoned on the island of lemnos
during the voyage because he had become injured
Odysseus and diomedes were dispatched to lemnos to
retrieve the arrows Odysseus tricked philosophies
into giving him the arrows and was ready to set
sail back to Troy diomedes on the other hand
offered to bring philosophies back to Troy with
them where they could heal his wound begrudgingly
he accepted velocities would use these arrows to
Kill Paris however on this occasion calcus was
wrong in his prediction as the war did not come to
an end he told the achaeons the only one who knew
how Troy would fall was the Trojan Seer helenus
diomedes accepted the task and found the Seer he
told the achaeans they would need to return the
bones of King pelops and so they did they would
have to find the son of Achilles and have him join
the war which they also did lastly they would need
to steal the Trojan Palladium a sacred image of
Athena Odysseus and diamedes disguise themselves
as Beggars and entered the city of Troy Helen
recognized both of them and wishing to return
home she assisted them in stealing the Palladium
Athena then appeared to Odysseus and gave him the
idea of the Trojan Horse under his instructions
the achaeans built a giant wooden horse that was
Hollow so men could be placed inside inscribed
on the horse was the message the Greeks dedicate
this offering to Athena for their return home
implying they were ready to return home and
wanted Athena's blessing there is no mention of
the Trojan Horse in Homer's Iliad Virgil's Aeneid
is the epic poem that really popularized the idea
of the Trojan horse the rest of the akaian army
had abandoned their camps and set sail to a nearby
Island to make it appear as if they had given up
and returned to Greece they placed the Trojan
Horse outside of the main gates to the city and
disappeared the Trojans seeing the empty camps and
no Greek ships assumed that they had won the war
in their celebration they dragged the horse inside
the city when midnight came sinon and acheon spy
signaled to the nearby Fleet it was clear for
them to dock the soldiers inside of the horse
climbed out and killed the guards they opened the
gates allowing the Greek forces inside the city
for the first time in 10 years the city burned
and the helpless sleeping Trojans were slain
in their beds the few remaining Defenders fell
and so did the city after a long hard 10 years
of war most of the Trojan airs were killed failed
the women were taken as concubines the Priestess
Cassandra was given to Agamemnon and priam's
wife hecuba was given to Odysseus Troy despite a
noble effort in defying the odds for 10 years was
completely destroyed almost every Trojan male was
killed and the once prosperous city was nothing
more than a pile of rubble one thing is for
certain there was only ever going to be one real
winner Zeus after all All is fair in Love and War